ever since it rebooted its hitman
franchise in 2016
io interactive has been putting on a
level design
master class the missions in the world
of assassination series
contain a huge intricate collection of
systems
that make them into giant clockwork
puzzles of creative murder
you got him 47. levels are designed to
be played over and over so you can
explore
understand and eventually master all
their moving parts
and it's impossible to see everything
one has to offer without multiple
playthroughs
at first hitman 3 appears to be more of
the same
it makes no drastic changes to the
underlying formula
with only a few graphical upgrades and
quality of life improvements
to the existing hitman framework but
hitman 3 improves on the series
through consistently excellent level
design mr gray is already in position
and ready to assist good luck 47.
hitman 3 is full of fun and fascinating
ideas
many of which play with the concepts
that have underpinned the last four
years of hitman levels
seemingly knowing that players have
spent all sorts of time mastering its
systems
io throws in some brilliant curveballs
that require you to use your
assassination skills and knowledge
in clever challenging new ways if you've
played the past two hitman games
you'll be immediately familiar with
hitman 3. all the mechanics
ai and ways you interact with the world
are the same that's key to the way the
game works
because your knowledge and understanding
make it possible to replay levels again
and again
to exploit their intricacies in
different ways rather than feel dated
hitman 3 highlights how satisfying it
can be to understand how
all these moving pieces work together
and they're just as impressive as when
the series launched in 2016.
we've gotten 47. soon there will be no
more providence
in each of the game's locations your
goal is to find a way to eliminate your
targets and then escape without being
found
you do that largely by knocking out
enemies hiding their bodies
and taking their clothes some areas are
restricted based on what you're wearing
and some characters can see through your
disguises requiring you to carefully
avoid them
agent 47 has the benefit of instinct a
vision mode that lets him see through
walls
and highlights interactive objects you
need to do some sneaking in each level
to learn about your targets
and find ways to get close to them once
you've got your opportunity
there are lots of ways you can carry out
an assassination you can just shoot or
strangle your target
or use more involved methods like
exposing an electrical wire in a puddle
to electrocute them the stealthier you
are and the fewer non-targets you kill
the better your score at the end of a
level and each stage is full of
challenges to complete
that encourage you to find weird and
creative ways to take out your mark
maybe something natural fitting the
season and local form
[Music]
some of what sets hitman 3's levels
apart is how they fit into the story
that's unfolded across the series
in the past each level has functioned as
mostly a standalone chapter
you'd go into a location with one or
more targets and uncover a bit of story
about the people you were after
which doubled as an opportunity to get
close to them but
those targets were usually tangential to
the unfolding story of agent 47 and his
handler diana burnwood
across hitman 1 and 2 the pair slowly
realized they were being manipulated by
a figure called the shadow client
who is using their assassination
contracts to attack providence
basically the illuminati in hitman 3
agent 47 and burnwood have fully joined
the fight against providence
and that means that missions feel like
they have a bigger impact and targets
are more interesting and make more sense
the levels are based on providence's
responses to your kills
which throws some wrenches into the
usual silent assassin format
after developing a brilliant mold for
hitman missions
io breaks that mold again and again to
create
fun memorable inventive assassination
experiences
you might have already heard about
hitman 3's excellent second mission
set in england where your assassination
takes place in the middle of a murder
mystery
you can even dress up as a private
investigator to find clues and solve the
mystery
in order to get a chance at your target
finding clues in the level's huge
mansion
is like playing another game in the
middle of hitman 3. the brilliance is
that
the whole time you're solving the
mystery you're thinking about how you
can share or hold back the information
you learn
to manipulate the characters and
accomplish your objective it's an
absolutely phenomenal expansion of how
hitman's intricate levels
already work thank you mr whitmer you
have not disappointed
i promised you i would reward you
generously if you solved the case
later missions also put intelligent
spins on the series framework just about
every hitman mission before now
has given you a briefing about your
targets and lets you plan your starting
position and weapon loadout so one
hitman 3 level
forces you to wing it locating your
targets and learning what you can about
them
on the fly another mission shrinks the
scope from a normally expansive setting
to a tight crowded train so that every
move and decision you make
has to be quick and calculated none of
these missions throw new mechanics at
you
or force you to learn new enemy
behaviors instead hitman 3 finds new
ways to challenge seasoned assassins
purely through excellent design you've
honed your assassination skills but can
you solve a mystery can you escape other
disguised assassins as they're hunting
you
it's a fitting testament to how strong
the world of assassination games have
been all along
that io can make hitman 3 feel fresh and
new simply by finding new ways to take
advantage of the series design
foundations
the drawback of hitman 3 is that while
its missions are the most ambitious in
the series
the game itself is scaled down somewhat
as an overall package
some additions that appeared in hitman 2
are gone including the competitive ghost
mode
and cooperative sniper assassin missions
you can still play sniper assassin in
single player
but only if you own that content from
hitman 2. still
you could argue that io is focused on
what people like about hitman
while letting less popular parts of the
game fade away but it still feels like
there's a little bit less game here than
in the past
that said these games have had great
post release content
and we know that at some point the timed
elusive target missions are making a
return
there's also the addition of virtual
reality support for playstation players
although we played on pc and thus
couldn't test it
and like hitman 2 hitman 3 supports all
the levels from the past two games
so you can play everything from hitman 1
and hitman 2
with your new unlocked weapons and
hitman 3's improvements
getting all your hitman content in one
place continues to be great
although you have to have purchased
those missions at some point or another
what's good about hitman its level
design and the creativity
experimentation and exploration that
affords is
great in hitman 3. it rewards you for
mastering the complexity of its levels
and of the whole series that came before
hitman 3 closes out the trilogy by
brilliantly playing off
everything that came before it and
subverting expectations
through its phenomenal design
[Music]
you